what you're talking about with taxes so
this is one of the reasons that i am as
passionately conservative as i am i mean
you mentioned at the beginning we were
talking right before we went on air
about my twitter mention feed because i
mean it's just a cesspool in there it's
not all roses and unicorns there's a lot
of people that are upset and
you know that that can be an
intimidating thing that can be something
that that people have trouble handling
and that's not been something that i
have cowered away from that's been
something that i've accepted as part of
my job and the re one of the reasons for
that is exactly what you mentioned
because my dad is a small business owner
and when i mean i can remember when i
was like 10 years old he paid me five
bucks to help him do his taxes like i've
been doing i was doing taxes with him
right but that's awesome right i love
that and so i knew how to do my own
taxes as soon as soon as i got a job i
did it myself i did it quickly and you
know you you gain an understanding then
for how something as
intangibly sounding to a child as the
tax code concretely impact your family
in your life so i understood then wow if
this if this politician is promising to
raise the corporate tax code like that's
going to have a negative impact on my
dad's business that's so important to
teach but that's such a boring topic
unless you have a hands-on experience
exactly and so i learned very young okay
so this is something like i'm fiscally
conservative because i see how it
impacts my dad which means how it
impacts me and all my sisters and
brother and my mom
um and
i think you have to have that kind of
imprint on your on your emotional
intelligence as well as on your iq and
the the other reason not to not to wax
too philosophically or the other reason
that i am so conservative too and the
reason that i'm so comfortable being a
skeptic in all areas um
is is because when i was in late high
school i was diagnosed i was i was
actually a competitive swimmer i was a
pretty elite swimmer and i was diagnosed
with a cell disease it's an autoimmune
issue and at the time i mean there
weren't there weren't many options the
doctors were just like okay you're gonna
have to live with this it wasn't really
a livable thing and my mom was like well
i'm not gonna accept that like i'm gonna
go search for
search for something alternative and
thank god she was able to you know find
an alternative way for me to manage my
health which i managed to this day but i
realized again that if we didn't live in
the type of economy the type of free
market that we live in my and my dad
hadn't had the choice to be super smart
with his finances and have a lot of
savings we wouldn't have been able to
afford
the treatment that ultimately saved my
life
that's something that has a really big
impact on you as like in your formative
years very emotional yeah that that you
know sometimes uh oh you you the the
money stuff like you make money and i've
owned all the crazy cars and all that
stuff i live in a beautiful home all the
you know people to have dinner with
but the basic things about money i had
one of our guys marroquin boris
marroquin he was at the house we're
having a cigar together uh salvadorian
husband and wife love these guys and
he's sitting next to me and uh we're
talking
and he starts crying
i said what's up what what's on your
mind he said well let me tell you what
happened you know
i used to not make a lot of money and
now making very good money and he had
made like 70 grand that month he says uh
you know i thought it's about the cars
and all the stuff he had his body bought
his wife and escalade and his him and
his wife have been together for 25 years
and he says but you know what was crazy
what there was a health issue that
happened with my kid and we needed to
spend six thousand dollars and it's very
private and we had to spend six thousand
dollars on the kid he says i had no if
it was a year and a half ago two years
ago
i wouldn't be able to do anything with
that i'd have to figure out a way to
make this i i was able to pay that six
thousand dollars he says to me
capitalism is that yeah that's
capitalism capitalism isn't another
three hundred thousand dollar watch
capitalism isn't another half a million
dollar that's capitalism now what we
have to consider i grew up in a family
where my mom was on welfare and we
didn't have money how we help those that
don't have access to the resources with
parents
that maybe you had like some people
don't have that
what do we do with them because those
parents
maybe don't have the resources that we
have to figure right away like you know
i was speaking to a school and they were
talking about how can we make our kids
uh better at processing issues and
there's this the
director of psychology the school's
having this conversation with me i said
how often do you guys have
a training just for parents what do you
mean like how often do you bring just
parents in all together in the
auditorium and talk to the parents about
how to talk to the kids at night and how
to have conversations with them at night
oh we never do that what do you mean you
never do that you know that in sales
it's about training the trainer that
whole thing train the trainer well who
is the trainer here the parent we need
to train the trainers the parents as
much as we're training the kids i think
we're spending way too much time focused
on the kids and we're forgetting about
the fact that that parent is sitting
there without access to resources can
you just teach me what you're doing by
the way let's just say 600 parents do
show up and let's just say 80 percent of
parents sit there like this right and
they're not even paying attention to
anything you're saying but say 20 that
do of the 20 that do 20 take notes and
go back and apply them one of the kids
ends up becoming a positive impact to
society and less personal relying on
government for taxes and resources we
did our part so i think there needs to
be just as much training with parents as
there is a very powerful way i think
you're absolutely you're absolutely
correct and you know where it is
happening today it's happening today in
the american homeschooling communities
so people think oh homeschooling so if
your dad happened to be a pharmacist
maybe he teaches chemistry you know the
homeschoolers turn to resources they
have resources standardized testing they
can get and books and things like that
but then they turn to the other parents
who's the expert on what and they do
some of the teaching for the kids and
they go to each it's almost like going
to class oh you're going to go to mr
richardson's house and learn about
chemistry because he's a pharmacist well
guess what's also happening parents are
getting together and the parents are
becoming educated on social issues and
becoming more aware
and handling discovering adhd or thing
or dyslexia and how to handle it and
manage it so it happens in the
homeschooling environment because the
parents are forming communities because
they know that there's things they don't
know and there's gaps and they want to
learn it pat that's where it's happening
and i think
a little conspiracy theory that
the society the left is less worried
about
homeschooling because of vouchers and
they're more worried about homeschooling
because of voters
because the parents are being changed
it's not the indoctrination of
tomorrow's voters they're being taught
wrong i think the parents are more
independent heads up and they're
learning in groups fyi
you know you know how all these guys
right now have uh courses online i do
course on marriage i do course on you
know such and such i do whatever the
different courses you can buy on udemy
pluralsight all these different things
you know what's a great niche that
people can take on right now that will
do very well
small courses on how to lead your kids
specific on leading your kids i don't
know how much of that is out there
anyways let me go to the next one i was
home thanks for the suggestion i gotta
go
let me say i think that's a great idea
that we do here at valuetainment this is
i mean this is exactly why you do the
sls symposium the sales leadership
symposium is that you talk about you
know why don't they do courses to teach
parents same thing you do with train the
trainers with php same thing you do with
sls i assume that's the reason you do
that is who's teaching the sales leader
to reinvent themselves right or to by
the way you don't you know how much
duplicate themselves you know how much i
would do this course let's just say we
do a parenting course i do it for 10
bucks 20 bucks because you want the
masses you want people to get it hey
here's
here's some strategies that worked on me
here's some strategies i'm using with my
kids i want to share it with you we
can't rely on the teachers to do it we
got to become better parents so the idea
is to train the parents if you're up for
it let's go through it if you disagree
with me fine maybe some of these tactics
are going to work i think there is a
market so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]